45 años. Han pasado 45 años desde que China
y Australia establecieron relaciones diplomáticas.
Desde entonces, amigos de VisualPolitik, las
cosas han cambiado muchísimo.
A lo largo de todos estos años, estos dos
países han cuajado una de las relaciones
más fructíferas, controvertidas e interesantes
de todo el planeta.
Una relación cocinada con historias de dinero,
espías, acusaciones, infidelidades y muchos,
pero que muchos intereses contrapuestos.
Si en vez de relaciones entre dos países,
estuviésemos hablando de relaciones entre
dos personas, tendríamos aquí un extraordinario
guión para toda una telenovela Latinoamérica.
Pero evidentemente, esto es VisualPolitik,
así que… al grano.
China es hoy el mayor socio comercial de este
país. Sus compras suponen ni más ni menos que
un tercio de todas las exportaciones australianas,
8 veces más que las exportaciones a Estados
Unidos.
Fijaos, en 2015 China y Australia firmaron
un acuerdo de libre comercio y hoy las relaciones
comerciales superan, atentos, los 155.000
millones de dólares cada año.
Y no solo eso, China es también un inversor
cada vez más importante en Australia, un
país donde, por cierto, 1 de cada 20 personas
es de origen chino; entre ellas muchos millonarios
que han decidió buscar un lugar más seguro
y con más garantías para sus patrimonios
y sus vidas.
(“Las relaciones comerciales con China son
de tal envergadura que los mercados financieros
han considerado desde hace mucho tiempo que
el dólar australiano es una de las mejores
opciones para apostar sobre la propia China”.)
Por supuesto, todo esto tiene consecuencias.
Hemos hablado ya de ello, aquí, en VisualPolitik.
Australia ha batido todos los records y lleva
casi 30 años sin conocer lo que es una crisis. Qué envidia, ¿verdad?
Pues bien, en todo este éxito el gran despegue
chino, como podéis ver, ha tenido mucho,
pero que mucho que ver.
(Ahora ya podemos entender, perfectamente,
por qué cuando el Lowy Institute, un importante
Think Tank del país, le preguntó el pasado
año a los australianos, qué relación era
para ellos más importante, sí la relación
con Estados Unidos o la relación con China,
se produjese un empate)
Y eso, amigos, que con sus colegas norteamericanos
las relaciones son, muy, pero que muy estrechas.
Sin embargo, a pesar de todo este romance,
lo cierto es que 2017 no ha sido un año precisamente
de amor entre Australia y China.
Atentos a estas palabras de Bob Carr, un antiguo
ministro de exteriores de Australia:
(Este año Australia declaró a China la guerra
“retórica”. Las palabras usadas por los
líderes australianos son las más ásperas
desde que ambos países establecieron relaciones
diplomáticas en 1972, con la excepción de
las declaraciones tras los acontecimientos
de Tiananmen. El tono es más duro que el
de cualquier otro aliado de Estados Unidos,
incluido Japón. - Bob Carr)
Tal cual como lo escucháis, 2017 ha sido
un año bastante difícil para las relaciones
entre estos dos países.
Tanto que una encuesta realizada por el Global
Times, uno de los periódicos más populares
de China, determinó que Australia fue el
país más hostil hacia China durante 2017.
Y la verdad, eso con Trump en la presidencia
de La Casa Blanca, son palabras mayores.
Pero ¿qué diantres ha pasado? ¿Qué ha
sembrado tanta discordia entre Canberra y
Pekín? Bien, veámoslo.
(LA TORMENTA)
A decir verdad, en un primer momento 2017
parecía que iba a ser un buen año para los
intereses chinos en Australia:
las relaciones económicas no cesaban de crecer;
Trump, haciendo gala de sus mejores dotes
diplomáticas, le colgó el teléfono al mismísimo
Primer Ministro australiano Malcolm Turnbull,
lo que hundió aún más su popularidad en
esta zona del mundo;
y el gobierno australiano incluso, se mostró
partidario, públicamente, de que China sustituyese
a Estados Unidos como miembro protagonista
del fallido TPP, el acuerdo de libre comercio del
Pacífico.
Vamos, que casi podemos decir, que en términos
de telenovela, el amor estaba apunto de triunfar.
Sin embargo, amigos, la tranquilidad... no
duró mucho… a mitad de año la cosa empezó
a torcerse. Y de qué manera.
Sí, vamos a ver… ya se habían producido
choques, pero nada que no fuese habitual.
El gobierno australiano, en los últimos años,
ha seguido una estrategia que, cómo decirlo,
consistía en tratar equilibrar permanente
su posición entre Pekín y Washington.
En asuntos económicos… guiños a Pekín,
y en cuestiones de seguridad y defensa…
Washington, por supuesto.
Ya os hemos contado aquí, en VisualPolitik,
que los republicanos consideran que Australia
es el mejor aliado de Estados Unidos:
Y no es para menos, fijaos:
(Australia es el único país que ha intervenido
en todas las grandes guerras de Estados Unidos
y, además, desde hace unos años las relaciones
militares son de tal calibre que Australia
se está convirtiendo en la gran punta de
lanza del poder norteamericano en esta zona
del mundo.)
El propio Primer Ministro australiano tiene
muy claro su aprecio hacia Estados Unidos,
atentos:
(“La paz y la estabilidad de nuestra región
han sido permitidas por el liderazgo global
estadounidense. Aunque ese liderazgo no hubiera
sido posible sin el poder duro de las flotas
y los ejércitos, su mayor potencia proviene
de los valores que encarna. A través de todos
los giros de la historia, los Estados Unidos
han defendido los valores en los que se fundó
su gran República: la libertad, la democracia
y el estado de derecho.)
Pero… regresando a la cuestión china…
fijaos, estas palabras que acabamos de ver,
fueron pronunciadas el 2 de junio de 2017.
Fue la primera vez que un Primer Ministro
australiano hablaba tan claro en favor de
Washington en un discurso, por cierto, cargado
de advertencias a China.
Pues bien, tan solo 8 días más tarde…
se desataba la tormenta mediática.
Varios medios se hicieron eco de una noticia:
La Agencia de Inteligencia Australiana estaba
realizando serias advertencias sobre las intenciones
del gobierno chino de influir en la política
australiana mediante diferentes medios, entre
ellos la compra de políticos, periodistas
y científicos; o la vigilancia y la intimidación
de ciudadanos pertenecientes a la propia comunidad
china en Australia.
El escándalo estaba servido.
(De repente aparecieron noticias sobre la
colaboración de universidades y científicos
australianos con contratistas militares chinos
o de antiguos políticos, como, por ejemplo,
el exministro de Comercio, Andrew Robb que
ahora trabajan para empresas controladas por
el gobierno chino a cambio de jugosos salarios
de cientos de miles de dólares.)
Veréis, los recelos y miedos de los servicios
de seguridad australianos ante el espionaje
chino no son algo nuevo....
Y los diferentes gobiernos australianos llevan
años bloqueando algunas operaciones corporativas
de empresas chinas, y también han prohibido
que empresas como Huawei puedan participar
en el despliegue de la red nacional de banda ancha.
Sin embargo, la polémica nunca antes había llegado tan lejos.
(“Los informes de los medios de comunicación
han sugerido que el partido comunista chino
ha estado trabajando para interferir de forma
encubierta con nuestros medios de comunicación,
nuestras universidades e incluso las decisiones
de los representantes electos aquí mismo
en este edificio, en el Parlamento”. Malcolm Turnbull.)
El 12 de diciembre de 2017, Sam Dastyari,
senador del Partido Laborista y una de las
figuras políticas más prometedoras del país
se vio obligado a dimitir por sus vínculos
con China.
Entre otras cosas se le acusa de recibir dinero
a cambio de realizar discursos en favor de
los intereses del gobierno chino e incluso
de haber alertado a un empresario chino vinculado
al Partido Comunista de que podía estar siendo
investigado por las agencias de inteligencia
y de que su teléfono podía estar intervenido.
(Científicos que colaboran con contratistas
militares chinos, infiltración en los campus
universitarios, pago a periodistas, políticos comprados,
las acusaciones se han venido sucediendo de forma constante desde el mes de junio…)
El gobierno australiano lo está denunciando
públicamente y ha comenzado ya a modificar
la legislación sobre espionaje, traición,
inmigración y también financiación de los
partidos políticos… y todo apunta, amigos,
a que esto es solo el principio.
Las consecuencias de este enfriamiento en
las relaciones políticas se está haciendo
ver, por ejemplo, en política exterior.
En 2017 se ha notado como nunca antes el giro
de Australia en favor de Estados Unidos.
Ahora bien, no penséis que esta postura es
unánime entre la clase política, para nada…
(“El gobierno no parece entender la importancia
económica de la relación con China o las
cuestiones estratégicas involucradas [...] estamos
poniendo toda nuestra fe en nuestra relación
con China a través de la lente de la política
exterior de los Estados Unidos" Paul Keating)
Y amigos, ¿Sabéis qué? No es para menos.
Por un lado, muchos críticos afirman que
realmente no hay tantas pruebas de toda esa
injerencia china que esta denunciando el gobierno.
Hay quien incluso afirma que todo esto es
una operación política alimentada por Washington.
Por otro lado, “romper” con China -o al
menos ser tan contundente con el gobierno
de Pekín- no es algo precisamente fácil
para Australia. ¿Por qué? Atentos.
(CHINA SE DEFIENDE)
En toda esta crisis política, China ha sido
contundente:
por supuesto ha negado todas las acusaciones
e incluso ha dicho que toda esta campaña
se basa en prejuicios raciales y en una clara
paranoia anti-China.
Una paranoia que han denunciado se está traduciendo
en una clara hostilidad hacia la comunidad china:
(“La diplomacia china alerta a los estudiantes
en Australia a permanecer alerta por riesgos
en la seguridad tras una avalancha de ataques” )
La verdad es que más allá de unos
cuantos carteles en alguna que otra universidad
no parece que haya evidencia de este supuesto
peligro…
pero si algo es evidente es que esta denuncia
por un lado muestra cómo están las cosas;
y por otro está claro no es buena publicidad.
Veréis, los estudiantes chinos suponen 4
de cada 10 estudiantes extranjeros en las
universidades australianas, y cada año se
gastan 18.000 millones de dólares en el país.
Sí, así es.
Podemos estar ante una primera advertencia
del gobierno chino dejando claro que está
dispuesto a jugar las cartas económicas como
medida de presión, algo que, por cierto,
ha utilizado recientemente con Corea del Sur
y Taiwan.
Pero no solo hablamos de los estudiantes,
sino también de los turistas o los inversores.
Por ejemplo, en los últimos años el sector
del lujo está experimentado todo un boom
económico en Australia ¿Sabéis por qué?
Atentos:
(“Los estudiantes, turistas y residentes
chinos en Australia son responsables de hasta
dos tercios de las ventas al por menor de
lujo en Sydney y Melbourne.” SCMP.)
¿Otro ejemplo? Las inversiones directas de
China en Australia se han multiplicado, no
por 10 ni por 20, sino por 32 en apenas 9
años. ¡Por 32!
Así que, como veis, un frenazo en todo este
proceso podría traducirse en mucho dolor
para la economía australiana.
En fin, amigos, así están las cosas.
De momento el gobierno australiano se mantiene
fiel a su estrecha relación con Washington,
Estados Unidos parece haber asegurado una
alianza imprescindible para sus intereses
en esta zona del mundo.
[Y también, por cierto, para su industria
militar. En los últimos años Australia
se ha convertido en uno de sus mejores clientes,
y en la próxima década espera gastarse más
de 100.000 millones de dólares en renovar
sus Fuerzas Armadas, y aquí los contratistas
norteamericanos parten con ventaja]
Sin embargo, por otro lado no son pocos, y
con esto me refiero a políticos, empresarios
y ciudadanos, quienes piden que Australia
se mantenga neutral y proteja su seguridad
nacional sin necesidad de realizar tantas
acusaciones públicas.
¿Cómo terminará esta historia?¿Estará
en riesgo una de las relaciones más fructíferas
de los últimos años? Solo el tiempo nos
lo podrá contar.
Pero ahora turno para tí, ¿Hacia donde crees
que debe girar la política australiana? Déjanos
tu respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.